so the the fact is a lot of people's
jobs right now uh are dependent less
upon like hey could AI do your job
theoretically it's it's more about hey
this organization uh like what are its
incentives uh and what are its resources
at a particular moment in time
um so if you're a university and let's
say I came to a University registrar and
was like Hey like you can get rid of
half these employees like you know I
need to just do this stuff with AI like
is the University's culture such that
they're going to turn around and do that
like maybe maybe not like maybe if like
a really hard time comes to that
University
um if you're a Public Employee it's the
same thing you know like the the issue
is that like healthcare when you talk
about the radiologist
um Healthcare is going to be one of
these protected Industries because even
if you can do some things with AI like
the medical Lobby will just be like it's
got to be human then there are going to
be certain workers in certain industries
all you're going to use ad agencies as
an example that comes to mind where it's
like we don't give a about what
goes on
that like the Ad Agency is going to be
like purely efficiency driven insurance
company same thing uh you know it's like
a financial institution same they're
going to be a very ruthless Market
efficient actor and if they look around
and say hey turns out I can do this this
uh Department's job with half the
workers then we're going to do it so
you're going to see different parts of
the economy respond in different ways
and I and I think that there's going to
be an instinctive sense of this and
people are going to go try and flow
towards areas that are more politically
protected that's an interesting Theory I
mean I I do think that the model that
people have of AI replacement where you
just walk in one day and you find out
that you lost your job and everyone's
been laid off and I think that's that's
never quite been true but I think it's
especially not true with AI because
what's going to happen it's not that the
hospital or the insurance company or the
consulting firm is just gonna you know
install some Ai and then fire 50 of the
workers the next day right it's going to
be more often that there's a new startup
that does a lot of the same stuff as the
hospital or the consulting firm or
whatever else but it uses Ai and so it
only has you know 20 people and it's
doing the work that the competitors need
hundreds or thousands of people to do
and is that small company takes over a
market share from this much bigger
company the bigger companies gonna have
to do layoffs and the smaller company is
going to stay pretty small I mean one
example I I wrote about in my book is
what's been happening in China with this
company called my bank my bank is a is a
lender they lend you know billions of
dollars a year for home and car loans
and stuff like that and their Innovation
is this proprietary automated system
that they basically claim can you know
evaluate someone for a loan and make a
decision about it with no human being
required it's a totally software driven
AI approach and because social media and
see if I seem reliable like what do they
do I have no idea
um they have it's it's probably similar
to something like a social credit score
or a regular credit score they I'm sure
they take some information from your
bank and they basically assess your
credit worthiness and issue you alone on
the spot with no underwriter or or you
know loan officer there to do it and
because they've been so efficient
they've been able to take a lot of
market share from these Banks and Loan
firms that have tens of thousands of
loan officers who are sitting there
manually you know approving the loans
and so you know those Banks and and you
know lending firms are going to have to
lay people off eventually because they
can't compete so that's I think more how
it's going to go
foreign